henderson nevada hitting a home run with  another las vegas-born franchise  indoor football league is expanding  dollar loan center arena  in henderson there will be home to the  new franchise knights owner bill foley  and ceo and founder of dollar loan  center chuck brennan  are thrilled with what they hope becomes  another winner in  southern nevada we're going to be  another destination  players are going to want to come here  and we're going to want to want to play  for us and i have a simple goal  playoffs in three and uh and the cup  in six okay period well there's three  things we look for we look for the  the quality the ownership group number  one we look for geographical location  and we look for  the what's the arena look like the least  look like and  they've checked all three boxes with a  marker here and  all right now the name of the team will  be announced soon foley told us  it will be tied to the golden knights  somehow guys back over to you